it is your best friend's birthday party
and you're getting late
your mum and dad are busy and can't drop
you to the party
what would you do simple call a cab
right did you know that every two out of
three
indians use ola to book a taxi ride
yes but despite having several options
why do indians prefer ola to its
competitors
let's see the story of how ola cabs
became
india's preferred ride calling app
[Music]
great ideas originate from empathy
and the ola story is no exception
it all began on the day when bhavish
agrawal
the co-founder of ola was traveling from
bangalore
to bandipur he rented a car for his
journey
initially everything was going fine but
all of a sudden in the middle of the
ride
the driver stopped the car and started
asking for
more money the driver even threatened to
abandon him in the middle of nowhere
if he did not concede bhavish however
refused to accept the unjust demands and
does
he had to give up the right but soon
after his pathetic experience with the
cab driver
bhavish realized that he was not the
only one who had faced such a situation
many of his family members and friends
had also come across such terrible
experiences
when it came to cab traveling some came
across
rude drivers some experienced breakdown
of cars
some had to pay unreasonable fares while
some complained about the cooling
or cleanliness where others choose to
complain
and eventually forget about the problem
bhavish decided to address the common
man's plight
bhavish and ankit party his friend from
iit days was already running a startup
that planned weekend trips by the name
ola trips
together they decided to create an
application where people could easily
book cabs
at affordable prices and enjoy
hassle-free rides
thus in 2010 they started
ola cabs but they had a mammoth
competitor to deal with
only two years before ola cab started in
india
uber had launched a similar app-based
taxi service
in the usa it was a massive hit
users loved the convenience transparency
and
quality of uber rides investors were
going gaga over the unique business
model of uber
it was based on an app that connected
users and cab drivers
solving problems for both uber started
expanding its business in many countries
outside the usa by 2011
uber was a giant in global markets and
was headed to capture the indian market
now ola had two options either to
succumb to the world leader
or to take on the giant and ola choose
the latter
so it was game on being an
indian company ola was more close to
indian consumers and their habits
so ola started building their uniqueness
around these characteristics
this was ola's power move firstly
they realized that all indian taxi users
are not very comfortable with an english
app
so they inculcated regional languages in
apps
to connect with ola users
secondly frequent internet connectivity
problems
made it difficult for users to make
e-payments
also indian consumers are always happier
to pay in cash
hence ola adopted a cash system to
enable offline payments
and lastly ola thought of a great way to
make cab hailing services affordable
for both drivers and passengers
uber was given an option of bigger cars
but a common man couldn't
afford it for his daily commute ola
added
small cars to their services in addition
to the existing range
drivers found it easy to invest in
buying small cars
for cab services the small cabs also
meant
lower fares because of low fuel and
maintenance expenses
this shot up the number of drivers and
taxis
thus giving passengers a lot of options
ola further extended this idea and
launched auto rickshaw
and bike services for the economy users
their introduction of carpooling was a
sure delight for the users
especially in i.t cities multiple users
could now share a ride
if they had common destinations
this contributed to reducing pollution
in addition to being pocket friendly for
users
this idea was a complete win-win
all these steps put them on a fast
growth mode
compared to their competitors did you
notice how
ola beat a mighty global player at their
own game
well it simply understood the indian
market better
they implemented innovative solutions
that created more value
faster than everyone else however
with the advent of many cab hailing apps
ola
faced a threat of losing customers to
the new players
but parvish and ankit saw these
challenges
as opportunities they decided to expand
in remote cities and small towns of
india
moreover ola created helplines for
healing camps
a customer could simply call and book a
cab
the local call centers managed customer
service in regional languages
ola also acquired taxi for sure another
similar taxi booking company
based out of india this move helped them
to grow in size
and be a bigger player others
tried to catch up with ola speed
but ola having introduced the common man
to luxury commuting
had the first mover advantage and thus
became the most popular cab hailing app
today ola cabs is a market leader with
more than 65 percent
market share and it's one of india's
fastest growing startups in the unicorn
club
did you notice how ola used innovation
and user-centric strategies to become
india's
best ride healing service ola teaches us
some of the best lessons
on how to fight with a mighty opposition
build an ability to hear what the
consumer wants and then be fast
in shifting gears so now if you happen
to come across such an opposition
will you follow ola strategy to shift
gears at the right time
do tell us your thoughts in the comment
section below
and don't forget to visit the empower
website to learn more about
entrepreneurship happy learning